over its impressive 17 seasons and
counting ncis has stood atop the police
procedural mountain the long-running
series has a serious knack for not only
making the crime drama stories important
but also giving its principal cast fully
realized backstories
one of the few drawbacks to this is that
now and again issues arise regarding
minor character details that leave fans
scratching their heads
one of the main characters of ncis is
leroy jethro gibbs
he's the no-nonsense leader of the major
case response team with a backlog of
experience in both the military and as
an nis
special agent these credentials are part
of what made gibbs such an effective
boss and he was often touted by his
co-workers as the most
capable and accomplished of them all in
the ncis universe gibbs began his
military training in 1976 right after he
graduated high school
he later served as a member of the
united states military police corps
before taking part in operation
just cause and operation desert storm
before his honorable
discharge in 1992 such a resume is
nothing to sniff at but there's one
aspect of gibb's past as a marine that's
causing something of a stir amongst the
ncis faithful
gibbs left his marine life behind after
killing mexican cartel leader pedro
hernandez the man responsible for the
death of his wife and daughter
despite the circumstances of gibb's
departure some ncis fans feel it's a bit
odd that after 16 years in the service
he stayed in the rank of gunnery
sergeant above staff sergeant and below
first sergeant and master sergeant
one viewer in particular has wondered
why gibbs didn't do a little more
climbing in the ranks before he cycled
out of the core
a reddit user posed the question i've
probably seen every ncis and now i watch
reruns
gibbs was a gunny sergeant in the
marines with his talent and leadership
skills why didn't he earn a higher rank
in response another redditor noted that
perhaps gibbs didn't move up from the
rank of gunnery sergeant because of what
happened with his family that caused him
to resign early
it's been a long time since the gibbs
flashbacks were a big part of the show
if i'm remembering everything correctly
i'd say he probably left the marines
after his family were killed
either finished his current enlistment
or was granted an early out for hardship
on the flip side there's a chance that
gibbs felt happy accomplished and
fulfilled
being a gunny that's not a far-fetched
theory in the least as the rank comes
with a great deal of responsibility
according to military.com the gunnery
sergeant rank is
considered the backbone of the marine
corps staff nco ranks
the site goes on to say marine corps
gunnery sergeants are expected to bring
their years of experience to bear in
quick
accurate decisions that are in the best
interest of the mission and their
marines
gunnery sergeants quote set the example
of leadership and professionalism for
their subordinates and must ensure that
work areas and facilities are up to
standard
equipment is maintained their
subordinates are following orders and
the day-to-day unit operation runs
smoothly in accordance to senior
officers policies
i am gunnery sergeant hartman your
senior drill instructor
from now on you will speak only when
spoken to
another possible reason why gibbs didn't
move up from gunnery sergeant to master
sergeant or first sergeant
is because it takes many years to even
reach the gunnery sergeant rank
one real-life marine noted that it took
them just over 12 years to become a
gunny
for another it took 13 years a redditor
wrote in response to the initial
question
gibbs left the core after 16 years the
average time to attain the rank of
gunnery sergeant is almost 15 years
if gibbs became a gunnery sergeant
somewhere between his 12th and his 15th
year in the core
there wouldn't have been much time to
advance whatever the case may be gibbs
continued to prove his skills post
marines becoming the ncis
special agent fans know and love today i
must fire my rifle
true check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one